when thinking about the life of bruce
wayne many can agree that his most
famous life event is his most tragic
most iterations of the batman story at
some point have depicted the event that
sealed his fate the murder of his
parents it's a moment that changes the
course of his life forever driving him
to create a symbol that the criminals of
gotham will fear matt reeves the batman
unlike so many previous cinematic
incarnations of the character does not
tread on this familiar territory when
the batman picks up it is two years
after bruce has started wearing the cowl
he feels the trauma of his past deeply
but it is represented more in what is
not said than what is
i don't care what happens to me
bruce has become reclusive hiding away
in wayne tower with alfred played by
andy serkis only venturing out around
people when it will help him solve a
mystery there are many aspects about
this version of batman that are
heartbreaking bruce's self-imposed
isolation and his inability to connect
to other people in a meaningful way or
just a couple and in the midst of all
the murder and mayhem the film depicts
it is one scene in particular that shows
just how sad the life of gotham's dark
knight truly is throughout the film
bruce has made it abundantly clear how
alone he is he goes out at night invites
as many criminals as he can when he
comes home the only person who tries to
forge a connection with him is alfred
but it's a one-sided effort if this
continues it won't be long before you've
nothing left alfred is concerned about
bruce's nighttime activities and why a
serial killer is leaving him messages
but for all of alfred's attempts to take
care of bruce the young wayne pushes him
away he tells alfred that he isn't his
father and doesn't accept his guidance
this dynamic reaches its devastating
peak when the riddler sends a package to
wayne tower while it's meant for bruce
alfred opens it just as a bomb inside is
detonated alfred survives the attack but
he is terribly wounded when he regains
consciousness in the hospital he and
bruce have a loaded conversation full of
pain and unresolved trauma both alfred
and bruce have burdens they need to
unload upon one another and when they do
it finally brings them together when
alfred first wakes up from his injuries
bruce is there by his side but rather
than express sympathy the dark knight's
first response is to accuse his longtime
butler of keeping family secrets from
him bruce lashes out upset that he never
knew his father had a business
relationship with known mobster carmine
falcone however once the two resolved
this issue bruce admits to being afraid
for the first time since the death of
his parents to cope with the loss he
became a symbol devoid of any fear by
becoming the personification of
vengeance he ensured he would never feel
powerless again but bruce acknowledges
that when alfred's life was in danger
being batman did not help he admits that
alfred is one of the only people that
means something to him anymore and that
losing him would be just as bad as
losing his parents bruce wasn't the only
one who has been holding on to past pain
alfred holds immense guilt over the
deaths of the wanes as he tells his
young charge bruce was just a boy when
they died and alfred thinks he should
have done better to protect the wanes
not only that but he never felt equipped
to take care of a young bruce or raise
him properly after being thrust into a
parental role alfred remarks that bruce
needed a father and he never felt that
he was good enough to fill that role he
blames himself for bruce's emotional
withdrawal repression and rejection of
the wayne legacy that said it is clear
that alfred holds no ill-will towards
bruce despite how cold their
relationship appears earlier in the film
this scene marks the first time both men
have truly opened up to one another and
it allows them to finally begin healing
their relationship
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]